Bonjour à tous et bienvenue, avant de démarrer
je voulais vous remercier pour l’accueil
très chaleureux que vous avez réservé à
la précédente vidéo sur les Peuples de
la Mer, visiblement ces thématiques purement
archéologiques vous plaisent énormément,
ça tombe bien parce qu'aujourd'hui je vais
vous présenter un site archéologique bien
précis l’abri Pendimoun. Cette vidéo est
en partenariat avec Echoscience Provence Alpes
Cote-d'Azur, avec qui j’avais déjà travaillé
il y a 2 ans, sur la grotte Cosquer (lien
petit i) et on a décidé de remettre le couvert
(oui car on va parler poterie, céramique..).
Plus sérieusement cette collaboration est
une occasion rare pour échanger avec l’archéologue
en charge de ce site, Didier Binder qui est
directeur de recherche (émérite !) au CNRS
et rattaché au laboratoire CEPAM à Nice.
Car après cette vidéo et pour poursuivre
la réflexion, une autre vidéo « Entretien
» vous attend.
Le Néolithique est une invention proche-orientale.
Il y a environ 12 000 ans, à la faveur de
meilleures conditions climatiques, de nouvelles
dispositions sociales et symboliques, des
populations ont commencé à se sédentariser
et à domestiquer des espèces végétales
et animales. L’Europe reçoit cette innovation
par diffusion. Les techniques et modes de
vie élaborés entre la Syrie, l’Irak et
la Turquie actuelles, sont apportées sur
notre continent.
Apportées, dans les bagages des populations
du Moyen-Orient, qui ont migré vers l’ouest.
La néolithisation, le processus par lequel
l’Europe voit dis paraître la chasse et
la cueillette au profit de l’agriculture
et de l’élevage, est la conséquence d’un
afflux de populations nouvelles.
On observe au Néolithique ancien, la phase
la plus précoce de ce bouleversement, deux
courants de diffusion à travers le continent.
L’un d’entre eux remonte le fleuve Danube
et ses affluents au centre du continent, l’autre
emprunte les côtes méditerranéennes au
sud. Chacun de ces courants a ses propres
spécificités culturelles, sa manière de
faire des maisons, des poteries et ses plantes
cultivées favorites. Et les pionniers les
emportent avec eux, toujours plus loin vers
l’ouest.
C’est ce que l’on nomme le “package”
néolithique, un ensemble de traits culturels
propre à ce nouveau mode de vie, et qui en
constituent la base. La trouvaille des éléments
de ce “package” néolithique, haches polies,
poterie, animaux domestiques, etc., permet
donc de retracer la progression des premiers
agriculteurs, à travers le continent.
Et autant le courant danubien avec ses maisons
longues et sa poterie à décor rubané, présente
une progression quasi continue et homogène,
autant le courant méditerranéen montre un
visage plus complexe. Cette migration par
voie de mer, traversant les baies et contournant
les péninsules, ressemble plus à l’errance
d'Ulysse qu'à une croisière de retraités.
Les sites archéologiques connus qui attestent
du premier Néolithique de Méditerranée
sont éloignés de plusieurs dizaines voire
de plusieurs centaines de kilomètres, et
les fameux “packages” qu’apportent les
migrants, présentent de fortes disparités.
L’abri Pendimoun est une étape sur cette
route. C’est, comme son nom l’indique,
un abri sous roche. Situé dans un relief
calcaire de la commune de Castellar dans les
Alpes-Maritimes, il trône à 690 mètres
d’altitude, quatre kilomètres au nord de
la ville de Menton. Sa localisation, à l’extrême
sud-est de la France, constitue logiquement
un point d’entrée pour le Néolithique
méditerranéen en provenance d’Italie,
c’est donc pour nous, un site capital pour
appréhender la néolithisation du territoire.
Les premières fouilles ont eu lieu dans l’abri
en 1955, avec une méthode un peu… radicale.
Une tranchée de 15 mètres de long est creusée
en plein milieu du site. Cela a eu le mérite
de montrer des résultats rapides et de révéler
tout le potentiel du site, mais cela a aussi
compliqué la tâche des archéologues suivants.
Cette tranchée empêche notamment de suivre
les niveaux d’occupation sur toute la surface
de l’abri et d’être parfaitement sûr
de la correspondance des couches de sédiment
de part et d’autre.
Je m’explique. Un site archéologique est
la plupart du temps constitué de différentes
strates de sédiments qui se sont déposées
les unes sur les autres. On trouve donc une
succession d’étages qui vont du plus ancien,
en bas, au plus récent, en haut. Ce principe,
très simple à comprendre, se nomme la stratigraphie.
C’est la manière dont les archéologues
visualisent le temps qui passe. La fouille
d’un site archéologique, ça consiste en
fait surtout à identifier les différentes
strates auxquelles on a affaire. A Pendimoun,
l’érosion de la falaise a apporté dans
l’abri de nouveaux sédiments de manière
constante, ce qui a permis de sceller les
niveaux d’occupation humaine et de conserver
de précieux vestiges. Mais la tranchée coupant
le site en deux a pas mal compliqué la lisibilité
de l’ensemble.
Toutefois, l'ancienneté du site vaut bien
qu’on essaye de relever le défi. De nouvelles
fouilles ont donc lieu à partir de 1985,
sous la direction de Didier Binder. Cette
fois-ci, elles adoptent des méthodes beaucoup
plus rigoureuses, cela va sans dire. Les archéologues
en plusieurs années de fouilles dans l’abri
identifient notamment un ensemble de couches
stratigraphiques, qui comporte des vestiges
du Néolithique ancien en abondance.
Parmi ces vestiges, la céramique attire particulièrement
leur attention. Les différentes phases du
Néolithique ancien méditerranéen se reconnaissent
en effet grâce aux motifs qui ornent les
poteries. Ces objets, utilisés quotidiennement
pour le stockage, le puisage de l’eau ou
la cuisson, sont décorés durant la première
étape du Néolithique, par des impressions.
Avec les ongles, une petite baguette, un coquillage
ou simplement en pinçant l’argile fraîche
avec les doigts, les potiers mettaient en
relief leurs productions. Les motifs sont
la plupart du temps agencés en bandes sinueuses
ou en plus grands aplats qui envahissent la
panse des poteries.
Une deuxième étape du Néolithique de Méditerranée
centrale et occidentale voit l’utilisation
massive de coquillages de la famille du cardium,
pour imprimer des vaguelettes sur l’argile.
En apposant le bord de la coquille dentée
sur le vase avant cuisson, les artisans pouvaient
facilement décorer les céramiques. Ce procédé,
qui supplante à cette époque les autres
styles de décor dans une large région du
bassin méditerranéen, a valeur de signe
distinctif pour les archéologues.
C’est pour cette raison que la première
étape du Néolithique de Méditerranée centrale
et occidentale est nommée Impressa, pour
ses décors d’impressions, et l’étape
suivante, Cardial, en référence au cardium.
Ces deux styles sont assez facilement différenciables
car ils s’opposent en de nombreux points
: forme des récipients, technique et structure
du décor, moyens de suspension et de préhension,
etc.
Au début de son occupation, Pendimoun fournit
une céramique originale. En effet, les décors
céramiques Impressa, sans équivalent régional
proche, notamment par son décor pincé, la
rapprochent davantage des styles anciens du
sud de l’Italie, notamment de Calabre, voire
des Balkans, plutôt que des sites voisins
du nord de l’Italie ou du sud de la France.
L’hypothèse privilégiée lors des premières
années était donc d’imaginer l’abri
Pendimoun comme une sorte de site pionnier,
une tête de pont de la néolithisation en
provenance directe de l’Italie du sud. Un
témoin privilégié d’une migration longue
distance, sans escale dans le reste de la
péninsule italienne. Les sites voisins, comme
celui des Arene Candide, près de Savone,
qui présentent des poteries décorées de
façon très différente, porteraient la signature
de groupes pionniers d’origine différente.
Un modèle séduisant.
Mais cette théorie qui met en avant une forte
diversité culturelle des premiers colons
néolithiques est aujourd’hui obsolète.
L’analyse technologique des productions
céramiques, réalisée dans un premier temps
à partir de l’observation des traces visibles
de façonnage, a révélé une surprise. En
2017 est publié un article montrant que les
poteries de Pendimoun ne sont pas fabriquées
par collage de boudins d’argiles horizontaux
comme partout dans l’Europe néolithique,
mais par l’utilisation de “patchs spiralés”.
Cette première analyse a été confrontée
ensuite, à une nouvelle technique d’investigation
: la tomographie. Cette méthode, qui consiste
à exposer les tessons de céramique à des
rayons X, permet d’analyser leur structure
interne et ainsi, de déterminer la technique
employée pour la fabrication des pots, même
sur des vestiges en mauvais état : et elle
a conclu aux mêmes résultats.
potier n’existe pas encore à cette époque,
et les artisans de Pendimoun confectionnaient
des petits rubans d’argile qu’ils enroulaient
sur eux-mêmes pour former des spirales, puis
assemblaient les spirales entre elles pour
former leur vase. Alors, dit comme ça, ça
n’a pas forcément l’air d’une information
incroyable, mais en réalité, pour les Préhistoriens
c’est une petite révolution. Pour comprendre
ça, il faut expliquer le concept de chaîne opératoire.
Une chaîne opératoire, c’est une série
d’étapes qui forment ensemble, une technique.
Étudier une chaîne opératoire, c’est
s'intéresser aux méthodes de fabrication,
d’utilisation, et même d’abandon des
objets.
Ce concept forgé par le préhistorien André
Leroi-Gourhan, puis repris par André-Georges
Haudricourt, a été diffusé en sciences
humaines par Jacques Tixier notamment. Il
est utilisé le plus souvent en Préhistoire
pour l’analyse de l’industrie lithique,
c’est-à-dire de la taille du silex, mais
il s’applique en réalité à toutes les
techniques. C’est un concept clé pour la
compréhension des sociétés humaines, par
l’intermédiaire de leurs techniques.
En effet, toutes les techniques nécessitent
un apprentissage, et se transmettent donc
entre artisans. En étudiant la technologie,
on peut dégager des filiations, des traditions
techniques. Et l’approche par la chaîne
opératoire permet d’appréhender les mécanismes
de pensée à l'œuvre chez les artisans,
aux différentes étapes de la chaîne. Cela
suppose en archéologie d’observer le plus
de traces possibles, pour reconstituer les
gestes à chaque moment de la vie de l’objet.
Le silex est un matériau particulièrement
propice à ce genre d’observations puisqu’il
enregistre sur sa surface, à la manière
d’un disque vinyl, toutes les traces d’usure
ou de choc. Il a pour cette raison été au
cœur de la création de la chaîne opératoire.
Mais ici, le procédé est appliqué à la
céramique.
A Pendimoun, l’observation des traces sur
les tessons, puis dans l’épaisseur par
tomographie a donc révélé la technique
de montage céramique par patchs spiralés.
Attestée sur toutes les poteries du site,
elle marque une rupture dans la technologie
du Néolithique ancien. Pendimoun est le premier
site sur lequel cette technique est identifiée,
par l’équipe de Louise Gomart.
L’analyse de trois autres sites italiens,
permet ensuite de mieux comprendre le phénomène.
Deux d’entre eux, Rippa Tetta en Italie
du sud-est et Colle Santo Stefano en Italie
centrale ont montré un montage classique
des céramiques en boudins horizontaux. Mais
le site ligure des Arene Candide, proche de
Pendimoun, révèle le même procédé en
spirale. Et depuis, beaucoup d’autres analyses
ont été menées. L’utilisation de la technique
spiralée est attesté dans de nombreux autres
sites et dessine clairement une frontière
technique, coupant l’Italie en deux, entre
le bassin adriatique à l’est et le bassin
tyrrhénien à l’ouest.
Étrange, car les schémas opératoires, les
maillons de la chaîne, ne varient pas facilement.
Ils se transmettent le plus souvent sans varier
pendant des siècles, cela est bien attesté
pour le Néolithique d’Europe centrale.
Il y a donc fort à parier qu’on ait bien
là, avec nos spirales, une culture différente
et pas une simple mutation locale. Les mutations
techniques se font plutôt graduellement et
par ajouts de petits éléments, en commettant
des erreurs, puis en se perfectionnant. Il
paraît improbable de voir apparaître une
toute nouvelle technique en quelques années.
On n’est pas passé du Minitel au smartphone
en six mois. Cette découverte suppose en
fin de compte, la coexistence d’au moins
deux groupes distincts agissant dans le cadre
de la néolithisation du Nord-ouest de la
Méditerranée au 59ème siècle avant notre
ère.
L’abri Pendimoun, considéré pendant un
temps, sur la base du décor céramique, comme
sans lien avec les sites voisins, se trouve
donc être en réalité, tout à fait intégré
dans une culture cohérente du Néolithique
ancien. Une culture différente de celle qui
a néolithisé l’Adriatique en provenance
des Balkans. Reste à savoir d’où ils viennent.
Qui a inventé le coup de la spirale d’argile
? Quand ? Et où ?
Des études de paléogénétique ont récemment
montré que les squelettes trouvés à Pendimoun
portent un pourcentage important de gènes
typiques des populations de chasseurs-cueilleurs
européens, ceux qui étaient présents avant
l’arrivée des agriculteurs. Les agriculteurs
pionniers se sont donc, à Pendimoun, un peu
plus mêlés aux populations locales qu’ailleurs.
De là à en conclure que la spirale est la
signature d’un métissage génétique et
culturel, difficile à dire, mais l’hypothèse
est séduisante. La clé de cette énigme,
l’origine inconnue d’un deuxième courant
de néolithisation méditerranéen, se trouve
encore quelque part sous la terre